The purpose of this segment is
to give you a little bit of
the bigger picture.
We did discuss some
inequalities, we did discuss
convergence of the
sample mean--
that's the weak law of large
numbers-- and we did discuss a
particular notion of convergence
of random
variables, convergence
in probability.
How far can we take
those topics?
Let's start with the issue
of inequalities.
Here, one would like to obtain
bounds and approximations on
tail probabilities that are
better than the Markov and
Cherbyshev inequalities
that we have seen.
This is indeed possible.
For example, there is a
so-called Chernoff bound that
takes the following form.
The Chernoff bound tells us that
the probability that the
sample mean is away from the
true mean by at least a, where
a is a positive number, this
probability is bounded above
by a function that falls
exponentially with n and where
the exponent depends on the
particular number, a, that we
are considering.
But in any case, this
term in the exponent
is a positive quantity.
Notice that this is much better,
much stronger than
what we obtained from the
Cherbyshev inequality because
in the Cherbyshev inequality,
we only obtain an inequality
for this probability that
falls off as the
rate of 1 over n.
So this falls much faster, and
so it tells us that this
probability is indeed much
smaller than what the
Cherbyshev inequality
might predict.
However, this inequality
requires some additional
assumptions on the random
variables involved.
Another type of approximation
on this tail probability can
be obtained through the central
limit theorem, which
will actually be the next topic
that we will be studying.
Very loosely speaking, the
central limit theorem tells us
that the random variable M sub
n, which is the sample mean,
behaves as if it were a normal
random variable with the mean
and the variance that
it should have.
We know that this is the mean
and the variance of the sample
mean, but the central limit
theorem tells us that in
addition to that, we can also
pretend that the sample mean
is normal and carry out
approximations as if this were
a normal random variable.
Now, this statement that
I'm making here is
only a loose statement.
It is not mathematically
completely accurate.
We will see later a more
accurate statement of the
central limit theorem.
In a different direction, we can
talk about different types
of convergence.
We did define convergence in
probability, but that's not
the only notion of convergence
that's
relevant to random variables.
There's an alternative notion,
which is convergence with
probability one.
Here is what it means.
We have a single probabilistic
experiment.
And within that the experiment,
we have a sequence
of random variables and another
random variable, and
we want to talk about this
random variable converging to
that random variable.
What do we mean by that?
We consider a typical outcome
of the experiment, that is,
some omega.
Look at the values of the random
variable Yn under that
particular omega, and look at
that sequence of values, the
values of the different random
variables under that
particular outcome.
Under that particular outcome, Y
also has a certain numerical
value, and we're interested in
whether this convergence takes
place as n goes to infinity.
Now for some outcomes, omega,
this will happen.
For some, it will not happen.
We will say that we have
convergence with probability
one if this event has
probability equal to 1.
That is, there is probability
one, that is, essential
certainty, that when an outcome
of the experiment is
obtained, the resulting sequence
of values of the
random variables Yn will
converge to the value of the
random variable Y.
Now, this definition is easy to
write down, but to actually
understand what it really
means and the ways it is
different from convergence in
probability is not so easy.
It does take some conceptual
effort, and we will not
discuss it any further
at this point.
Let me just say that this
is a stronger notion of
convergence.
If you have convergence with
probability one, you also gets
convergence in probability.
And it turns out that the law
of large numbers also holds
under this stronger notion
of convergence.
That is, we have that the sample
mean converges to the
true mean with probability
one.
This is the so-called strong
law of large numbers, and
because this is a stronger
notion of convergence, a more
demanding one, that's why this
is called the strong law.
Incidentally, at this point, you
might be quite uncertain
and confused as to what is
really the difference between
these two notions
of convergence.
The definitions do look
different, but what is the
real difference?
This is quite subtle,
and it does take
quite a bit of thinking.
It's not supposed to be
something that is obvious.
So the purpose of this
discussion is only to point
out these further directions
but without, at this point,
going into it in any depth.
Finally, there is another notion
of convergence in which
we're looking at the
distributions of the random
variables involved.
So we may have a sequence
of random variables.
Each one of them has a certain
distribution described by a
CDF, and we can ask the
question, does this sequence
of CDFs converge to
a limiting CDF?
If that happens, then we say
that we have convergence in
distribution, and this is
more or less the type of
convergence that shows up when
we deal with the central limit
theorem because this is really
a statement about
distributions, that the
distribution of the sample
mean in some sense starts to
approach the distribution of a
normal random variable.